By.
Monday monday night you know
where i can talk about it.
Benny zabel and. I am a.
Very good at visual presentations
you know painting. And.
Using my bodily movements to express and.
I'm here in nimbin working to help
the aquarius 20th anniversary.
Form into some sort of.
Good energy.
My entities. You know i have
sort of formed the number of.
Characters. Well after the
query is first of all in.
73. There was a lot of people around with
the entity is an interesting entities
and i transform benny's a willing to zany
bubbles from just transposing the bean
the and and any case i
was doing bubble images.
To bubble form of expression.
Then i was agreed those are in
company was the actual came out
and it sort of developed in the 80s
and in 1980 on. When i got involved.
You know i decide to take
my more skills into the.
We activists forum.
And have developed this character for the.
For the movement. A bit
of a shock shock image.
Well the greed those are in company
and it's sort of got known as a dollar
man because if the great dozer flashes
dollar and sintered into dollars
destroying the environment with a dollar.
Or you know using the
dollar as a as a weapon.
It is so i came here in 1973.
With a performance troupe
we called ourselves the.
The classic forget the name now.
The mad metaphysical magic.
We call our so many physical matter which
we came with a performance on how do you
wells which we trumped up was a time machine
we trumpet up into sort of like the
mechanical people and the beautiful
people you know sort of the mechanical
and the people in the more free
spirit living on the earth
and you had the mechanical people live
done of the which was a sort of split the
h.g. Wells of how the society will
split in the future and i played it.
I played it's time traveller
and i mean we sort of was very interesting
if it really worked because it was very
fitting to the environment
but when i came here.
Our props ended up taking
off to. See brisbane.
So we were out in the field there
and we setting up a sort of.
A spot
and i ended up doing dance workshops every
morning in them in town hall for throughout
and then went towards the end of the
festival we had our props down we did our
performance as we.
Just sort of you know
that the group of us just went
around just did things all around
or so much going on. You
just sort of participated
and just became more freeform in
in participating. Around the.
The the area around the site area.
And participating in forums and
raging with the different bands
and getting with other
people and doing things.
Well the highlight was
doing the performance.
It was quite missed mysterious event.
The acoustic was in the in the bush factory
before was the bush fact it was all the
scaffolding set up and i remember
we had the screen up there and.
And i was i use the scaffolding
to get these dramatic sounds
and it just sort of created these
dramatic so because we had these.
We had this sort of beautiful white
garments which it turned around was black
and and skull.
And so we had this sort of contrasty
images of the sort of just really light
carried them
and then then with the light show we had
tom pollock doing poetry rove you know tom
and he was doing sort of the sort of
freeform pollock tree interludes to interact
with the with the people in and telling
them the story of the time machine.
So it was semi we used the script as
a sort of improvised improvise on
and seems the movements. So it
was all that sort of hang it on.
On that and
and interacting with people with fruit
you know coming out with bowls of fruit.
And with that with the the law either
sort of beautiful people and then then.
Sam angelica was the executioner
sort of chopping off people's heads.
You know with these magic in terms of.
When we doing the the
mechanical stuff and sort of.
Processing going.
Very interesting because that place
the bush fact he was a meat works.
And in the later days and.
Had a nice energy there then.
Still got a nice energy there.
Oh the bush video here that was set up by.
A whole group.
Combined group of people which for
which just from the universities the
universities we were just getting
into sort of porter packs.
Having porter packs and then.
Interacting with the community on on
issues and people can take the tapes out
and people can go out there and make.
Make make their own video what's
around them and get feedback
and just was sort of
that process just came on on the
market so group came up here
and decided to set up a.
Set up a whole network with within the
like with the cable link up for the site
just ideas and
and just developing their technology as a
sort of an internal monitoring of what's
going on. People went out in the
field and took out the packs
and videotape what they
wanted and. You know.
And then brought it back and it was shown
out to people. People just look at it.
In the site which is.
Yeah well that is all it was all done by
young people never didn't know about it.
It's just sort of their.
Learning about it a lot of
and even people within the field are just
learning about how to handle this this
equipment. So it's quite a you know
having it's quite expensive too.
Oh a member that had one
highlight was a birthing
that took place on at the
at the first i saw that
that was quite incredible actually a birth
at the aquarius vessel was actually.
Monitored back from the
day before two people
and just the whole thing was
quite a culture shock for me.
But that was that was that was one
of the things i was the highlights
and was on on the on
the on the box around.
Special post things around town.
Well you had different stages for one dollar
brand was a high one of the highlights.
He was doing music you know he'd be doing.
Long stints of piano playing
really beauty from south africa.
Was great and i used to go down and dance
and do interact with dance with people
and get these things happening
with them develop these sort of.
Things that was part of my thing.
It was not only was i. A dancer.
You know so i trained dancer turned into.
You know freeing up the form but i developed
in that form through the melbourne.
Early stages in melbourne in that sort
of late 60s and 70s interact with bands
and sort of become a cat are used as a
sort of a catalyst a form of catalyst to
together. There was a name that.
I developed a name for it
was sort of like a crowd.
A crowd stimulate or
something like that a crowd.
You know and i've got had i was
doing things that this goes
and where i be on stage and i go out
and do things in the congo lines
and little groups stand thing arrays
you know just sort of just tie.
It all ends up so there's a focus. So for
you. So take take the whole dance thing.
Interact with them things so you get these
groups things happening with band of
people.
And the other things are just other things
that took place during the things was
just there was also still a petite
doing is highway that that really was
amazing. And there was the room.
I he sort of just. You know put up.
It just sort of coming with a
unicycle and you'll see string up.
You know just this. Thin.
Thing guy with the black hat he was
dressed in black with coat tails and
that you know just coming
in and i'll draw this line.
You know
and you start doing this thing with the
first of all he clearly the space by using
a unicycle to clear the
space and just shouldn't.
And then draw the line around and did all
that sort of traditional french sort of
mime type sequences to get to committee i
was no voice it was just miming
then he had these juggling
and all the sort of things.
That's pretty much in vogue
with with street performers.
Now
when he was a sort of he brought it pretty
fresh into this country wasn't very vocal.
Then it was probably was
probably a first rate performer.
Doing it in australia because it was pretty
much like it was a strange scene he had
to go through some strange scenes
here because it was pretty much.
The authorities wouldn't allow
him to do these sort of things
that wasn't there wasn't a forum for it.
These things have to be
battled down the track to
when you know getting by laws passed that
people could do these things but it.
Firstly just sort of like the aquarius
festival's a good forum for him to try this
have seen it was an open. If. Open.
Social.
Forum to try out new
ideas and free theater.
In many forms were taking place
not only just philippa teeth
but he's the string up the wire and
he did that you know between the pub
and tomatoes i remember.
And you know sort of the modus of which
the neighbourhood centre you center now
and used to do the thing there in
jungle and how it just amazing. Just.
Did these things and he had a reputation
of of stringing up the. The high wire.
On the not to dam and high places
around the world he sought and he did
when he went to sydney tried it
did it on the sydney harbour
and they say they started
the take down his rope
when he was up there authorities freaked.
It was a really dangerous he was
like to actually undoing the rope
when he was up there and see these things
like. Pretty dangerous thing to do.
But he was he was a highlight.
I mean sort of just observing him
in there was fred robinson and his.
Urantia rays you know it is this whole
new agey this whole connection.
In new age sort of
thinking that way around.
It was the food you know that sort of
trust food thing and food kitchen was all
that sort of. Cooperate. You know people
on trust and cooperation. The whole.
Festival was based on.
Just allowing animals the shitters like
this were whole things they was quite think
that was one of the first was well the
first time i ever went to a festival where
where where everybody just there was in a
circle in any shape in a circle like you
know it will have this circle
and it was all open there was sort of
mixed it was you know was no sort of
sexual sort of decision everybody came
in there and just composted there.
The spot on the bottom you became ill.
You know was the whole awareness of you.
I was very good because they became
aware of your own bodily functions
and broke down a lot of. Mr.
Myths from living in the city and there
was there was another good thing and
and there was the saunders
and. Sort of these things.
And just being you and the
bamboo bridges across the creek.
Was the form of this it all these
things all these huts and things
that we've built out of all these
diverse lorraine array of dwellings
that we've put up and.
And remember our theatre
group developed a.
Sort of the well developed dwelling you
know relating to our little sigh i think i
was interesting. It was pretty.
Ratty tatty but it was sort of you
know we never done it before.
But we set it up and was the place where
we got under was plastic and and bamboo
and stuff. And kept the
and there was always sheltered
and we had a shelter up. You know.
I came to nimbin well like a lot i just
came you know with the with the trip to be
part of this festival because i was at
festivals like it's not the first festival i
went to i was part of the sort of.
Festival dress like i had a lawn and
before and i wasn't turn on then it was.
My pongal and. And. And in victoria.
We had.
Was it was sunbury years
it was the sundries and.
The one before that casting it was known
but there was a few of
these sort of events
and also being part of you know indoor
events. With much more boring and.
I will ask of sort of intermedia.
Get togethers. And. So yeah. So there was.
There was a connection and
that's when i got here
and it's just just widen the whole.
You know what what festivals can do like
festivals where actually setting up social
you know he really can learn
from festivals. A lot.
I mean there's this that you
learn about society is as it is
and people learn there and it can change
that the learn to change because
you just set up experiments
and it's only temporary.
I mean it's something that's going to be
temporary but you can really go for it
and just do it. As a as
a microscope on ideas.
With everybody.
I stayed on because then it was the
the ideas of getting a community.
Well getting a property.
Many for many reasons to get a whole
lot of property so that the people
that are here have a place where they can
keep their ideas going like develop their
ideas from the experience
from their career festival
and people had different ideas like
that the total commune idea of like here
we are living here during the aquarius
festival forming this is a society
where we all care and share
and do everything you know get
some problem try and do that.
And it was that sort of idealistic
idealism that i was around at the time
and also very poor people you know
very poor at the work something.
How we do it and and also people
that had dropped out as such.
And
and were shunned upon in different ways
because they were not part of the status
quo and. Types and they
were students as well.
Because there was there's disillusionment
there's a lot of social reasons why this
stake in place the disillusionment with
the whole was this with the wall with the
war mentality and and the whole
philosophical discussion about about
that attitude towards you know
we had real social problems
to sort out and let alone.
The the earth in getting back to the garden
the sort of was the sort of spin off
from woodstock itself like as well.
And that that was it that had a big impact
on me. You know like woodstock itself.
And i guess a lot of people here i
think doesn't it was a hidden thing
and this became the sort
of australia's woodstock.
That's how it turned out to be i don't
i don't know who was intentionally
but it was what the university had in mind
it was going to be a woodstock. But it.
It was that because woodstock was
also when i was over in america.
I discovered that and reading about it.
That was the same thing was going on
there was that disillusionment and
and as it all these philosophers
and writers in these issues
and trying to express a different
world from the world of of.
Of competitive.
Smashing and pushing and killing
and raping to something
that gets back to the earth
and gentle caring all
that sort all those sort of that sort
of society like develop a society in
that sort of way
and they've given the name aquarius.
How did that. Progress. Well it meant.
We just have to work on our ideas
and i mean it's so to me it.
It's been successful because. It's
successful as much energy as what.
All have discovered and certain
and a lot of what what has been experimented
on is made itself into the mainstream
like the mainstream just takes the
cream of ideas that really you know
that they think can work with mainstream.
And you know you have alternative healing
processes the health health food said you
terry. An ism. That's been advanced
from. That sort of thinking the.
All these different co-ops and that
around the place you know. And the wall.
You know listen less people getting
away from thinking about about fighting
and finding solutions to
consider good solution and.
This quite you know just a
lot of just in the health
and healing aspect there's heaps in.
Permaculture and that's developed
but it sort of grew out of
that interest in the earth
and an alternative of internet
to monarch culture that's for
people living on the
earth here and realising
that modern culture is destroying the
earth but it's just part of that thinking
that that's lateral thinking it's not
that there's not that sort of level
that where you think
that society because this is the way it
is is the way it can't be changed from
there because you upset society when actual
fact that you that there is a role for.
For dropping out
and trying out ideas as part
of the creative artists role
or taking on that role. Yes always.
I enjoy that whole investigate the
seeking role and i find this.
That's a real.
It's not not new it's not even
aquarius was just the time
that sort of just highlighted i mean that's
goes on throughout the ages in if you
look back. Any really get into into
that you have this sort
of line of thinking
that goes right back in time since.
Humans upon the surface or
have been that you know
that development has created
the world we were in
that sort of civil civilizational
thing is just part of the concepts
that came out people to try
and. You know the sort of that.
How we live with the earth
and the creatures around us.
And then we have all these problems
and then we are going to solve these
problems so needs certain things you have
different and communication.
You know communication
and communication change like you have
the renaissance period which was a real
change in our times in relation to the.
That stands out because it was a radical
change with technology because i was also
to do it. Mix mixing with technology and
and the other became this sort
of technology that arrived in
that time the printing press. And the.
Building a whole lot of you know
architecture building and temples.
And it was a sort of european sort
of connection going on the sort of
internationalization
happening. To the post.
Post roman empire times and sort of coming
out of the middle ages and so that this.
Coming out over boyd so that there was
that that was a sort of the period
that sort of and a spiritual awakening.
This also spirituality is part of that
process that's something else that's that's.
I found here in the emblem that a.
There was investigation into alternative
spirituality there was a disillusionment
chris did you do day. I mean basically we've
the people that came to this. Occurs.
Were people from that sort
of a christian background
and quite disillusioned because
that sort of really created.
That world that that we rebelled against
and sort of laws which sort of related to.
Punishment and guilt and all that and
was sort of free ourselves from the.
Annual so you had a christian is he also
vegetarianism the christians were part of
that sort of culture that
that was around and they.
And
that was they were here in terms of they
brought their culture their culture here
there was or can't i.
Malay are spiritual groups of sort of new
age christian groups as well sort of
and then buddhism
and buddhism took off as quite strong after
chris first of all that's really came
quite a strong thing as and
it was in my direction
and i mean not even
really become a buddhist
but i had a very they had a big impact
on my life is is being able to sit
and i'm serve in a life you know you
know activity and become aware and
that sharpen my awareness and still
point and yoga. That sort of bodily.
Thing you know you know going
taichi all these things
that you could do out here in this special
place this place just turned out to be
so special with the rocks in the valley.
You just create a special
precison energy about this place
and then there's the aboriginal
connection with this place and.
A lot of things just the mystery of this
place is something special about remember
and i cut my finger on.
I don't know anyone people
just put their things
but i certainly have the magic
which sort of. It creates a.
Inspiration.
Yeah i yeah i guess it's good coming
back to the place and see the.
That the place is not being very radically
altered even though we're sort of
fearing this going to be radical
alterations coming up now.
But it's also that there is that.
There's a there's just. This people.
There's all these hives and connections
are still there. If you look for it.
It's around all those sort of
connections with all that accrue stuff
that happened during aquarius first of
all is is around you know in the area.
Oh well this is my little artistic
little do laws actually it's a sort of
self-seeking. And in
externalizing it. In terms of.
There's only bubbles right. Well zany
bubbles sort of grew out of the.
Well after the queerest festival.
I just decided to change.
You know create this character. Before
that i had a red pair of tights and and.
You know i was i just had just
ordinary tights and dance things and.
And you know the time traveller
was pretty much costumes and
that terms of it was just
a part of the performance
but now i wanted to do it as an environmental
piece by going to expand my ideas.
And also as a clown character and
because it was sort of a community now
and i just want to expand it that i
just came to my head just an idea
and.
So i just started developing and
but it was in the 60s was
it was in early 70s 70 71.
And 69. That was overseas. 69. And.
Just started to. Did a series of
paintings which were on the bubble.
It was sort of drift bubbles drifting
through voids and and out of flames
and into crevices and
coming out of clouds and.
And and going through amoebas and.
Just and different and getting the spirals
and just the dots getting
into all these sort of.
Other images you have to look at it
and i just created this whole working
with with with time and space it was.
And shape. And just exploring it
and just from that's around all.
And if i draw in the ground or
you know sort of getting into
that meditation of doing.
Circles very simple and just the idea
spinning off one after the other.
And so i did a series of canvases
in melbourne big canvases and.
They never really completed because.
Completely because i was part of a
community at the canterbury arts centre.
We started a group of us broke away
from the pram factory carlton scene
and wanted to start something away but it
sort of got lumbered with the council.
So really you know. So it was
you know sort of a ritzy area.
They couldn't hack us you know was
right aaron in. In the electorate of.
Of.
Prime minister of the time you
know one of the prime ministers
and so you know sort of it sort of was a
whole lot of really you know sort of locks
and closed
that got more expensive than the council
wanted to rip this big theatre down into
something else and we started a residence
group there and for the save save the.
But that that whole to beautiful
buildings there the old buildings.
That's another story. But i was into
that to about this high rise stuff
that was in carlton at the time
and so i did paintings of all
building probably all. Environment.
That was urban stuff.
So i wasn't sure i thought.
Well from that it was so well
that that developed later on
and so there's only
bubbles was the character
but i didn't plan to paint the shop fronts
and then when was that is just i had
that and i. And i had.
I didn't i was seven years
later when i came to nimbin
and i was i was only
bubbles at the time. And.
And. Graeme duffin actually
wrote to me. Melbourne.
So so spending six months down here.
Up here put put money into have exhibitions
and i did all buildings and places
and and workshops in melbourne.
So they had to hold connection family
connections in melbourne. And.
Relationships and that sort of
thing so down in melbourne.
And then i came up here to develop the
ideas in this sort of social experimental
you know get together which even.